I have constant pain in my growing from it to we're growing on my bladder pressing on a nerve can the right machine be helpful what settings what can be done for constant pain.
Well, the right is going to be most beneficial to be running the programs that I wrote for you to kill the cancer so as a cancer decreases in size than the pressure the physical pressure on that nerve.
You would think at least would decrease as well and the pain would decrease.
We have had people that run the pain program on the right there's pain bio one and pain bio two there may be another few pain programs there could also think of inflammation run inflammation program there's several programs for inflammation.
We should try those programs.
I would try them. I mean some people have used those programs and told them it was like miracle.
Told us it was like a miracle. Some people said I've got it any good. Well, because it's just didn't that program specific frequencies didn't help that person.
And some people have just said it's a miracle. So I would try those those two programs. Also, I would just try to run the your day programs as much as possible to.
So again, when I was really really sick with my cancer, I was just running my same I wasn't running different programs unless they have it's just running the same you know program for annual carcinoma over in over again, almost 24 hours a day.
And that's really what turned me around.